today we'll be going over games that
feature tactics along the long diagonal
that is the H 8 to a 1 diagonal okay so
does everybody here heard of the phrase
fianchetto it's Italian for on the flank
or on the side okay so it's basically
when you put your bishop on the long
diagonal there's a lot of good tactics
that can arise so this is a game played
from over the weekend at the mid-america
open White is a Eric Tang chinko Black
is Michael comer me so I'll be the hero
all right all right
so black counters with c5 this is called
the Sicilian offense
it's basically he's controlling d5 and
f5 I'm controlling that's important d4
squared if he puts anything on d4 I'll
take it alright Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 solidifying d4 but white plays d4
anyway which is OK so black trades his
side pawn for your center pawn so
everything is looking pretty good so
this is a really standard opening a
really standard position you'll see in
the Sicilian opening all right so black
plays g6 wanting to get his bishop on
the long diagonal white plays a very
fishy move here plays b3 this is not the
main line so he wants to to challenge my
bishop my fee on cattle bishop with his
own fee on keto bishop okay
but it's weak it's a weak move so now
this night as we see is in a pin so when
pieces are pins we usually want to
attack
okay but if we attack them with E 5 as
we saw from last week that would be weak
because it would give ourselves a hole
on D 6
we don't want to do that because he
could plop right in on B 5 and then take
the whole and Plus now if you play e5 if
we play d5 the Knights no longer in a
pen because it blocked up the bishop all
right in other way we could attack its
Queen to b6 but white could just protect
it with c3 okay and obviously we don't
want to take this night because there's
two players on it but he has two
defenders so the math doesn't doesn't
add up because Knight takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen takes and then it's
got his Queen in the center real nice
okay
so we don't want to attack the pin piece
but we don't want to just let this a
prime position go free
so what move would you be considering
for a black here Queen to a5 check all
right I like it and that's what I play
in the game okay so now he's in check
all right so if he blacks let's say with
the Queen see this is one of his key
defender so we would take Knight takes
and now he's only got one defender on
the night and we have two attackers so
he would lose a piece all right so let's
let's hear some other ways he can he can
get out of this check and not lose his
knight I knew somebody was against safe
through c3 okay and it looks it looks
good it does look good I'll give you
that just not good enough
so c3 so it looks it looks like
everything's going good I block the
check I got another defender on my
knight life is good but is it no what
can you tell me about this C pawn it's
pinned so it's not doing what it
normally should do right so how many
people in reality
you're protecting this night one just
the Queen all right but we have to be
really careful here it's like okay the
night's free let's just take it oh you
have to actually calculate out how you
should take it because you have two
different ways to take it but how should
we take it all right so everybody yelled
out bishop all right so Bishop takes
because if we take with the night it's
still okay we're going to get up a pawn
but how is white going to going to get
at least a piece back here pawn to b4
okay
then we'd have to retreat our queen he
take we take take and now we be up upon
okay but so we play check he played c3 a
dubious move to to get out of the check
but when we take with the bishop all
right and now he tries before what's a
really cool move that we have so we
actually keep the piece because if we
move the Queen he'll take the bishop
right yes we take this pawn here and if
he takes this way we'll take Queen check
and now we have two players attacking
the bishop so if he if he plays like
Queen here remember we just take and
then Bishop takes Bishop along the long
diagonal and if he takes our Bishop here
now what move do we have it's kind of
tough to see
night to see to double-check the Queen
cannot take this night because this
Queen is also delivering a check all
right then you can't play Bishop to c3
for the same reason so he has to play
King to e2 we take the rook he takes
back and then all we have to watch out
for is him pushing this right so we can
just get rid of all that with Knight to
f6 makes sense and then he doesn't have
any tactics along this long diagonal all
right so so now everybody we shouldn't
want to play c3 we don't wanna play
Queen to d2 so what's the only move
white can do to get out of this
predicament King to eat - yeah yeah yeah
so this is this is what happened in the
game you had to put spy not how he uh
planned it out this is this is a
notebook that I've ever seen so you
really don't wanna yeah yeah you really
don't want to be a Yankee knowing this
Bishop to counter this bishop unless
you're strongly prepared to do so okay
so so he's got this so now his king is
stuck in the center is our King stuck in
the center no where you can still castle
so that's what we want to do before we
go on any kind of a big attack here we
want to make sure that we're castled and
secure so knowing that we'll play Knight
to f6 attacking the pawn if you pushes
the plan we'll take it with the other
night so he protects this pond with f3
now we castle the safety we're castled
by move eight is this how you would be
plains Eve just arias Kings in the
center let's just get safe no no but now
you know that's how you want to play get
Castle first and now we don't have to
worry about getting checked all right
but Eric
his Kings not in a good spot he's got a
lot of pieces on the back row so what do
you think he plays g4 attack attack that
King but he's pretty safe he's pretty
safe I don't know that little pun is
going to help him but we'll see
so black plays d5 just when he was
thinking about okay break open the
center now there a king is safe d5 so he
takes takes our guy so take capture back
nothing difficult about that so he takes
d5 now we can get another tactic now
that he he's taken that night off of a
d4 with with taking and so forth okay
now we have tactics again on this long
long diagonal so whenever we move this
knight anywhere we go the bishops are
now attacking each other right so
everything is looking good but if we
take if we move here now if that's even
legal it's not because he took our pawn
and if we take Knight takes pawn
he'll just trade off Bishop takes Bishop
you know and nothing gained nothing lost
right so when we move our Knight what do
we want to say after we move our knight
in our dream scenario
sure yes checkmate would be would be
good but we want to say check because
when we move this Knight if we can say
check then guess what we get a free
bishop right obviously that wouldn't be
checked though all right so we need to
check the King all right so where does
that King have to be III f2 sound good
but we can't just say hey Eric move your
king alright just doesn't work that way
alright so how can we try to tell them
hey move it put them in check all right
Bishop to a6 check
I like it too and of course he goes okay
alright so he moved to a dream position
or you'll see if Ken Westin get the
right movie for that position
yeah but but that's rude that were been
fine I would have been very happy if you
were to play at c4 because now we take
with the pawn and now we're attacking
the pin piece so so King to f2 so he's
not actually down any material until
well but but his Kings there Knight
takes g4 check we could play Knight to
e4 check but that's no fun you want to
take take something is like okay oh
thanks as I well you're not going to be
thanking me in a minute alright so
Bishop takes b2 all right so so now
things look very dire for for white in
this position g5 well he kind of wants
to at least get this Bishop for this guy
right so this is important at home and
for everybody else if they play Knight
to c3 here all right we have an option
we can take the rook and then he takes
or we can just take the knight for free
you always want to take a free piece
okay you don't want to give them
anything back so that's how you would
take if you have the option between
winning up piece or winning the exchange
always pick winning the piece okay well
if we took with the Queen then it kind
of makes our bishop immobile take them
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
another well yeah oh yeah so yeah we
play Queen takes Knight here we would
take the bishop on a6 and then that
would unleash another defender of a1 and
then we'd be looking pretty good for
well well why would still be losing but
not but not not as bad not as bad yeah
you should just take in the free piece
alright alright so so okay so but if he
plays Knight to d2 here he's in a lot of
trouble as well because Bishop takes
Queen takes and then Queen takes Knight
check so what is he gonna do
so right now no no he's only going to
lose in exchange if he can figure this
out
all right look so so look we want to
really put our knight on D - right like
really bad but we can fantastic so
Bishop takes a six so he took something
I want to take it back now we can play
Knight to d2 and think hey you can't do
nothing alright so now I cannot take the
knight back so we only managed to lose
an exchange here so he's still
technically in the game so so I'd take
the punt so so now of course he still
wants to checkmate me right that's what
he want to do the whole game so what do
you think he does plays to try to get a
checkmate attack going you don't have to
get this right
plays h4 yeah it's roar when in doubt go
for go for the throat go for h4 all
right so black could take the the
coward's way out and play Queen to f6
check but but then I lose my past I pawn
my D pawn is kind of weak and it's not
very fun right yeah I want to checkmate
- right so I play the move e5 okay so
you're like oh man you just drop the
pawn but it's not going to be very cool
or you dropped another pawn and then you
might as well just call it a day for a
white bull okay all right so so e5 is
good move all right so he's like I don't
care all right whatever
so he plays h5 I'm going to checkmate
you right so so it's so it's got a
couple different checkmates ideas with
the move h4 okay here you go
h5 h6 and see how that's protecting the
Jeep the g7 squared and he's going to
checkmate me over there are you just
going to break open the H file and get
us Queen over there and check maybe so
he's got it's got a lot of good ideas to
checkmate me but they're a little slow
there are a 5 so h5 all right so now I
decide I'm going to protect that e pawn
rook a to e8 so Queen to c3 now ask
yourself why do you play that
oh yeah he wants to get over here and
checkmate me
all right so lots of different
checkmates here so I'm like ok go over
there so he's like okay thanks alright
I'm over there alright so II for
threatening check the pawn fork okay he
sees it plays Knight to c4 so like I
can't resist free pawn alright and so
now he's thinking life is good pawn
takes g6 threatening checkmate alright
so so who wants me to play III to try to
get out of this checkmate then he plays
King to f3 right also Queen to c2 check
does not work either cause a king here
Queen there it would just have to be a
draw alright so so
wait what oh all right take it all back
now that I thought of something if queen
Tex check King to there I'll play Queen
to d1 check and then I'll take the
coward's way out check but there's
nothing wrong with that and then I'm
winning all right
but after takes where it's my third and
final check yes pawn takes pawn a
discovered check all right and so now
the Christopher Columbus check there it
is discovery all right all right so
white decides he's gonna come down and
take my pawn and checkmate me but he
can't because he's in check too bad and
look at what PC touched oh the Queen
yeah yeah he thought he was about to
checkmate me and unfortunately he can so
so he's got to put his Queen there and
then there but he decides hey he'll just
call it a day after he touched his Queen
so if your opponent even tries to make
an illegal move with the piece doesn't
matter if they can legally move that
piece sorry you have to it's your
responsibility no if you're in check or
not okay so so that's so that's that
okay so always enforce that alright it
yeah yeah so so he touches it in the
tournament chess it's touch move so if
you touch a piece you have to move it so
he touches his Queen - checkmate me
unfortunately that's not legal but he
does have a legal move with this Queen
right so he touched the piece even
though he didn't attend to move to f3
with the Queen you have to sorry buddy
and then you don't even take your play
Queen check first then and really hurt
them so now we all know about
tactics along the long diagonal so in
the next game everybody should be able
to solve this tactic even though it's
probably right at the 1400 level okay so
I hope everybody can see it this is my
my last round game but it was really
easy because I just saw all those
tactics along this diagonal so it was
fresh in my mind okay I yep I get black
twice in a row yup just like I called it
all right so so white plays d4 Knight to
f6 Knight to f3 g6s where you want the
bishop on this long diagonal it's like a
gold mine out there III not the best
move you don't want to be blocking in
your pieces when you don't have to
so Bishop the g7 C 4 alright
d6 Knight to c3 and you're like Mike how
in the world is there going to be a
tactic on this diagonal there's 1 2 3 4
5 pieces in the way well really four to
get the rook but four pieces in the way
you just have to be patient okay that
ever happened Castle it happens sooner
than you think
Bishop e2 another kind of passive move
alright don't need to be playing this
passive as White Knight B to d7 Castle
II five you put another piece in this
long diagonal unbelievable it's not
going to happen so pawn takes so now you
take another so we want space this
Bishop can't move so we take back with
the knight okay alright so what does he
do
I couldn't believe it when I saw it b3
I was so excited pawn
to be three all right so take a take a
good good look be three alright so
what's going on he just so now this
bishop is attacking this rook through an
x-ray and now there used to be four or
five things in the way now there's only
three so what can you tell me if all the
knights get out of there our Bishop has
a clear shot at the rook but the only
way that would work is if it's our move
right if all the knights get out of
there and it's white the movies like oh
boo that was real tough shucks
all right so we need to get rid of the
Knights and and he figured it out
Grandmaster Ken Wes all right so II for
pawn to e4 so Knight takes free night
huh free night now wait are you happy
for black or happy for white right now
who black because he's got you say it
well what's he got isn't going to go
here
good night takes f3 check so now even
though it's rooks under attack it
doesn't matter you got to deal with the
check so he takes and Bishop takes and
then it's a pretty easy victory from
here there's nothing there's nothing
else well in my mind see what the
computer says but there's nothing else
in my mind he could do after 94 if he
tries to protect it it's going to be the
same thing right Knight takes check
Bishop takes it takes Bishop Bishop ok
nothing you can do
all right so so 94 very good alright so
if you see that's the power of this dark
squared Bishop all right just be patient
and immediately took until move 11 and I
got I got his rook some good
alright so the game pretty easy from
from here on out but you want to limit
the counter play okay
make sense c5 pawn takes e5
no no first things first first things
first [ __ ] up to a 3 another discovered
attack ok alright so Bishop back to e5
attacks the upon their now c5 takes
bishop takes when you're up you just
want to Trey
there's nothing easier than winning a
one game everybody should repeat that at
home because everybody thinks oh it's so
tough to win a one game it's really not
this is a one game and it's not
difficult you should be basking that hey
I'm up I'm winning oh one game a one
game is basically a position where
you're winning ok so say like in
basketball you up by like 10 points ok
it's pretty easy or if you this goes by
like soccer scoring so I'm up by two two
goals in soccer right it should be
pretty easy to win that game right all I
have to do is play a little defense
you know just make sure that it doesn't
get any good scoring chances and I'll
win because I got that two-point
advantage so but a lot of people say oh
I mean it's so tough because what
happens when you get a one game is your
tend to relax and your opponent he's
backed into a corner now he's down by
two goals he's going to be taking out
his goalie trying everything he can to
beat you like like Eric did last game
pushing all his pawns short my king
right so what you want to do is just try
to trade-off material try not to make
anything
so like confusing limit the
complications of the position make it
easy for you to win and how do you do
that is by trading the material okay so
so that's why we took his Queen and and
so forth and so so now he's attacking
our rook
so we move our rook g3
so [ __ ] about five you want to trade
we'll trade so when you're losing you
probably don't want Trey material
because if you trade off everything
you're done
so Knight to d2 so that's a it's not the
best move so what do you think black
plays he just rook yes so we get our
last guy into play and we put the put
the guy in the pin okay so he's got to
move his uh night away so we take Czech
Bishop takes and now would just tell
this bishop to go away b6
oh wait so he can't resist taking our
guy so Brooke takes bishop okay so now
he attacks our rook oh so we could play
that but that would give him a free move
so to avoid complications we just
retreat all the way to the back row so
now our can't really get attacked the
worst move for white as everybody will
know in this position Hereford black is
to play f6 here alright no reason to
give them any kind of checks with the
King okay so you don't want to play f6
in this position there's no reason to
and plus it loses a pawn right off the
bat so don't even think about playing
that alright so c5 alright a tax Bishop
to e5 still don't want to resist the
urge resist the urge because remember if
you were following our classes the last
couple weeks
one f6 no good ever and second if you're
up material right in an endgame you
should be able to win a free point you
don't have to trade this
pawn for this pawn you should be able to
have a material advantage you should be
able to just win it outright okay so how
would we go about winning some of his
pawns now what would be our idea so so
you see he's got this undefended pawn
and this undefended pawn how would we go
about trying to get them so attack the
bishop I like it so so yeah how would
you do that with the rook right get the
rook on the active file alright and now
we got free reign to do whatever we want
here so Bishop to f3 so rook to d2 I
think rook to d3 is probably fine - but
rook to d2 so if he plays a3 we have a
fork go pump but he plays efore all
right so remember resist the urge to
make things complicated
just move it
Oh Bishop h3 is there going to be any
kind of checkmate foreseeable even if
that white bishop wasn't there no no
checkmate so just Bishop e6 get them all
in a line here alright so so he goes to
another attack here so Brook takes a to
f5 now unfortunately this is another
mistake people make when they have a
one-game all right they move too fast
it's like oh I can do anything it
doesn't matter I'm crushing him okay so
if I was thinking what move would I make
in a heartbeat Bishop takes b3 game over
unfortunately up my bishops attack I
guess I'll move it
I move it backwards it's a big mistake
all right
so when you have a one position try not
to move so fast h4 Rick d2 so now
instead of winning my palm write up my
work has to go on a mission to get it
so Bishop Bishop attacks my rook rook
the d3 King F 2 so rook takes b3 all
right
so pawn takes g6 here okay so he's got
to try something to try to beat me here
all right
all right so how should we how should we
take back the H pawn good because we
don't want to be susceptible to these
checks all right so if you can keep your
King safe it makes your life a lot
easier
yeah I like them
b5 no so the only way I'm going to win
is if I get a queen so what move should
I make should I move this pawn this pawn
or this pawn move the one closest that's
going to get a queen okay now you say no
man what happens if he plays here we
just shut who's just no we will check
and then keep pushing them okay because
that's the only one we're worried about
getting right now all right so he
doesn't play that instead he keeps on
with his own threat h5 I don't know but
it's happening it's happening so we see
that he has really no threat here so
we'll just take take all right so so
what is White's dream
scenario here checkmate checkmate so
let's say I start playing like an idiot
okay it's black move again he gets a lot
of moves so this would be his a ideal
setup check checkmate
okay so let's not let that happen we
could we can just try to stop that all
right now okay so he wants to get there
and there and and his bishops on those
nice diagonals drew my king so we can't
really stop him from playing bishop here
bishop here right does everybody agree
okay good xiv agree so that's one all
right but we can stop him from playing
here and here without repercussions
anybody see a good defensive move here
Bishop f5 why not why not just make it
so he's got no hope all right
you want to make moves that almost make
the guy want to resign or at least die a
little inside like that move would do
it's like oh man I was going to do all
those cool things to you don't give him
any kind of hope no hope all right so
now he plays the move Bishop here like
you wanted to and now we just check and
he doesn't even care where he puts us
King is like okay wherever so just keep
marching that pawn h6 that doesn't look
so scary now that we have a bishop here
right so check them again King to F to
keep marching that pawn and now he's got
one last hoorah here Shaq all right
yeah so so a lot of people are laughing
but it turns out he's going to be
threatened checkmate in a minute here
alright so so take with the bishop and
now he plays Issa --cs alright so pawn
takes six bishop takes and now black and
self mate if you will it once where
should this King not go like the last
thing you want to do is accidentally put
this King here corner game over
alright so so let's just not go there
and everything will be okay so there's
no checks now he's out of checks right
unless he just wants to give me a bishop
yeah exactly
even though he got all those checks in
at the end well three he gave it up he
gave it up and so that's the game so so
now hopefully everybody knows go to the
last check so everybody knows that's
what you should be playing that's what
you should be doing always fee encounter
your Bishop on g7 and then just wait for
the tactics to have them be patient and
they will happen but once they happen
you have to strike instantly because
they're not going to wait around forever
okay